democrats and republicans they are
squaring off over what to do about the
historic level of student debt in this
country americans have racked up more
than 1.7 trillion that's with the t
dollars in student loans spread across
some 43 million borrowers now that's
second only to home mortgages is the
largest category of debt in this country
at o'keefe is in washington where the
president has already forgiven billions
in student loans and he's heading that
more action may be coming on that and a
lot of people crossing fingers toes eyes
and legs and hoping that this comes true
good morning to you good morning gail
he's forgiven about 17 billion dollars
in student loans so far and everybody
else who's a student loan borrower has
had their payments put off until at
least august because of the pandemic
there's an expectation that he's going
to announce something about forgiveness
in the coming weeks democrats are
pushing him to do as much as he can
republicans are not trying to block him
it's predatory there's nothing else you
can call us a 40-year-old mother living
in detroit megan douglas graduated from
the university of michigan in 2003 with
20 thousand dollars in student loan debt
the whole time that
you are
not earning enough to pay back these
debts now you're you're accruing
interest still
and so it's like getting punished
for being poor
douglas took out twenty thousand dollars
more to help get a master's degree but
after years of interest when her
payments resume she'll face a debt total
that's nearly double i have a quarter of
my salary left to
buy food take care of my child and then
it becomes unsustainable life just
becomes unsustainable at that point with
the average cost of a four-year college
degree climbing to more than 115
thousand dollars democrats like senator
elizabeth warren argue president biden
can cancel student loan debt without
congressional action
40 percent of the people have student
loan debt
don't have a college diploma they tried
but pregnancy they were trying to work
three jobs their mom got sick 40 percent
of that 43 million
are dealing with student loan debt
college loan debt
on what a high school grad makes to
those who say and you know this argument
that's not fair
i paid my debt what would you say
that four-year college that you can get
by on a part-time waitressing job it's
just not there and what america has done
to those kids is we've told them on the
one hand much more so than when i was a
kid you need post high school education
and the only way the federal government
is going to help you is to load you up
with debt and then squeeze every last
drop out of you to pay back canceling
student debt would also be grossly
unfair
to the americans who worked hard for
years to pay off their loans republicans
agree rising costs are a problem but
they've introduced legislation to block
the president from forgiving student
loans i question whether he has that
authority at all
whether the president does have the
authority has sparked fierce debate and
the education department has yet to come
to a conclusion regulation
is much more likely to survive legal
challenge
loan forgiveness for lower income people
may be more legally viable according to
student loan expert mark catrowitz but
it won't solve the central problem loan
forgiveness is a one-time event
it doesn't increase college access or
graduation rates
and it doesn't help future students
douglas says without action many
americans will be faced with some very
hard choices i'm hoping beyond hope that
we don't miss this opportunity to
do right by a whole lot of people
now before he left for asia the
president met with lawmakers again to
discuss this issue and like we said a
decision is expected at some point soon
polls show a majority of americans
support at least some kind of loan
forgiveness and that's likely to factor
into the administration's decision given
that the midterm elections are just a
few months away
nate
ed thank you